uh what do you think about as a small
tangent
um Johnny Depp Amber Heard trials going
on it's a quick pause it's going to
resume
next week so again this is one of those
situations where
you know I have very limited information
because I'm also not sitting there
watching the trial yeah have you watched
any of it little bits of it and it's
like I know that if I go there then I'm
going to want to watch it all yeah it's
good I know I really it's raw
Human Relationships that is most toxic
at its most deep also because there's
you can tell there's love probably still
there's love which is the interesting
thing they probably still love each
other even though they hate each other
um and like there's a lot of lying going
on it looks like it's Amber Heard lying
to to my foolish eyes it seems like
she's lying non-stop but you know I want
to know the full story and we'll never
get to know it but you see this Raw
like post-mortem on a relationship On A
Love Affair that was clearly passionate
there was clearly something deep of a
connection there and it just that's the
sad thing about love it can destroy you
as much as it can uplift you so there
would be also used to destroy people
yeah to manipulate and all that kind of
stuff yeah right so people who
um feel that strongly are I think
particularly vulnerable
um yeah it's
it's hard to talk about because
I've dipped into
like a podcast or something where other
people are we're discussing bad vegan
and like a pop culture way and they're
analyzing it and it's so annoying to
listen to because I'm like oh my God
that's totally wrong that's totally
wrong well if they only knew this well I
have nope that's wrong so it you know
yeah listening to other people analyzing
um
my situation or my psychology when they
don't have all the information has been
really frustrating
the difference I did there's a
difference because the world doesn't
know much about you except for the
Netflix documentary right there's a lot
more information about both Johnny Depp
and Amber Heard and the trial is
revealing the real people this one is so
interesting but I haven't watched it all
okay but but there's the difference
between a documentary and like a raw
human being exactly the real trial you
could see the body language the it's so
interesting that I think you could tell
the difference between a person
who is full of [ __ ] and not
I no I'm not sure
no it's another I'm gonna I can't
remember and sorry just I keep
interrupting you but on top of this
they're actors too which is very
annoying because right exactly because
like I don't know if they're putting it
be sure as hell it looks like Amber
Heard is putting on
um like a soap opera act soap opera
meaning like really bad acting of like
and lies but I would say all of these
things are really hard
people would say about me I don't look
like a victim and I don't mind you
interrupting me because Andrew huberman
said that's that means you're interested
you said it was a good thing
so you don't have to apologize I think
interrupt me it keeps coming up but I
keep thinking of these that that's one
of the things that Andrew told me that
I'm like I are you sure because it just
doesn't seem like an [ __ ] thing to do
I don't I guess it depends on the
context if we're in a business meeting
and and somebody you know talks over you
to kind of make their point heard but if
it's a one-on-one situation then it's
not all right anyway forever but so a
long time ago I listened to there was a
audio call um an audio that was released
of a taped argument between Johnny Depp
and Amber Heard
um and I don't remember why like which
one of them had taped it and if they
knew it was being taped but it was like
an hour and a half and I listened to it
almost like you would listen to a
podcast where I was doing other things I
was like cleaning my apartment and I was
fascinated listening to it to a fight so
I was and it's interesting too because
it was just the audio not so you're not
looking at their body language
um which can be completely misleading
and there was another podcast where they
talked about how judges make worse
decisions
on whether or not somebody deserves you
know parole or to be released on bail
when they see the person in person
versus if they're just looking at the
information on paper
so I think body language and those kinds
of things can be can actually be
misleading or we think that like by
looking somebody in the eye we'll know
if they're lying or not but the skilled
Liars are able to
bypass that or they
because
I'm jumping all over the place but one
of the things about sociopaths is
they're not going to have the same tells
so like if I was lying somebody would
know because I'm like stressed out
mortified I'm probably doing all the
things that we do when we lie because
it's stressful for me whereas they don't
have those things so I think that you
know they could for example I think that
they could pass a lie detector test
they also don't have like a startle
response so that's interesting the
activity in their brain like if you and
I watched something graphic and tragic
on TV or watch something happen like
things would happen in our brains that
don't happen in the brains of sociopaths
so they don't react to things in the
same way that
that we do again but that makes them
keep assuming I'm not associate I didn't
say I'm not a sociopath this assumption
you keep making is very interesting then
why did I murder all those people let's
get back to the um what were we talking
about Johnny Depp and Amber Heard so the
audio that I heard made me without
knowing anything else made me very
inclined to be team Johnny Depp
yeah based on that based just based on
that audio Yeah well that's how the
people are feeling about this whole
interaction by the way I do think it's a
very healthy thing to do in a
relationship is to record each other for
months at a time uh every time you fight
that just seems like a very
um sarcasm I don't I don't understand
how they because they both recorded each
other
it it's just it's okay I suppose you
could look back at all human relations
and be like this was ridiculous what was
I doing
but when you're in it you don't
right I wondered that too like who made
the recording and why and
um
and did they both know about it that it
was being recorded sometimes they did
sometimes they didn't
uh all I know is just the Poetry of
Johnny Depp's speaking and sort of
um
movement about the whole thing it's
interesting it makes you wonder what's
real maybe this is whole maybe maybe
they're both in love and this is like a
a troll that they played on the world I
don't know
it makes me wonder what's real at all
uh like I
because there you have to remember
they're actors too
yeah I don't think he would have filed
the lawsuit if no I mean I'm joking no I
know but but no I mean my point is
um yes yeah if somebody was trying to
make the argument that like he's the
abuser
and that he's lying and he's full of
[ __ ] it sort of doesn't make sense that
he would have
filed the lawsuit unless he's trying to
have this all
come out in the open
Because he believes he's in the right
you know again I don't I have no idea
as a fan of love and human nature I
appreciate the fact that they went
through this I know it's probably
extremely painful but it's it's
fascinating to watch
Human Relationships be presented such a
railway and so it made me realize how
rare it is to get a glimpse like that